[Music]
when retired world war ii general dwight
david eisenhower ran for president he
was hailed as a military savior and
all-american hero from the plains of
kansas
[Music]
washington now is the time for all good
americans to come to the aid of their
country
vote for eisenhower no one expected that
in his farewell address he would
identify and oppose the emergence of a
new power constellation the military
industrial complex
in the councils of government we must
guard against
the acquisition of unwarranted influence
whether sought or unsought
by the military industrial complex
the potential for the disastrous rise of
misplaced power exists
and will persist
we must never let the weight of this
combination endanger our liberties or
democratic processes
his was a prophetic speech especially
for a military leader who saw that a
fusion of government and corporate power
could lead to what he called unwarranted
influence and misplaced power
[Music]
fifty years later on the warning's
anniversary president eisenhower's own
granddaughter susan documented how the
military industrial complex had grown
she wrote in less than 10 years our
military and security expenditures have
increased by a hundred and nineteen
percent
this new book on the clout of the
military industrial complex by william
hartung details the power it wields he
told me how it works
military contractors uniform military
the pentagon
basically pushing their interest at the
expense of taxpayer national security
uh and some cases are civil liberties
is it a description of an actual reality
well the military-industrial complex is
probably more real now than it was when
eisenhower coined the phrase
a company like lockheed martin not only
are they building missiles they're
building cluster bombs they're building
uh you know submarines at the same time
they're helping process your taxes
they're counting the census they're
running fingerprint databases for the
fbi so it's kind of morphed from just
the military-industrial complex to sort
of the national security state so you've
got surveillance as well as weapons
building
hartung says these companies in effect
dictate our foreign policy
they've sort of
captured our foreign policy and captured
our military policy
really for special interest purposes to
large degree
writer david swanson believes that this
military industrial complex relies on
wars or the threat of wars to stay in
business
president eisenhower pushed war
propaganda in the very same speech and
throughout his career but he could not
have been more right i think he he
probably did not imagine how huge the
problem of what he called the military
industrial complex would become it i
describe it as a banker bailout every
year it is a trillion dollars over a
trillion dollars every year
into the machinery of mass murder it is
over half of federal discretionary
spending from the u.s government it is
as much and more than all other nations
of the world put into the military each
year
it is much of it unaccountable
the pentagon routinely loses quantities
of money that are as much as most other
governmental departments get
it's not just that more money is being
spent on farms but the rise of the
military-industrial complex has been
accompanied by an overall rise in
corporate power and not just in the
military sphere
military contractors now have
disproportionate influence says sheila
krumholz of the center for responsive
politics
there is a huge uh sum of money coming
from defense contractors in particular
and these range from at t and boeing the
largest multinational kind of goliath
their primary source of revenue may be
telecommunications or
or transportation but they have huge
contracts uh
worth a ton of money with the dod and
and
military there have been a number of
pieces of legislation aimed at both
making that connection more transparent
and
trying to put a lid on
the kind of pay-to-play uh
method that has ruled for instance
earmarks
have we seen a pattern of military and
industrial
collusion and and an industrial you know
companies that do business with the
pentagon giving more and more money to
politicians many defense contractors
were
making contributions spending lots of
money to lobby uh and
in exchange winning uh contracts that
maybe they weren't the best
uh organizations to uh to benefit from
so there has been an a a lot of research
done about about how money uh greases
the skids for defense contractors i'll
also say that the revolving door
plays an important role so it's not just
money it's other forms of elite
influence where people in in the
department of defense are kind of lining
up their next their jump to the private
industry where they can rake in uh
huge sums of money in lucrative posts in
private industry that they used to
regulate
alongside the military are huge
intelligence agencies with vast budgets
to spy run covert action operations
collect personal data and conceal how
powerful interests operate today the
former head of cia runs the pentagon and
was replaced by a general
the head of the navy seals runs the
central command secrecy is pervasive in
a national security state even as groups
like wikileaks try to disseminate hidden
information
wikileaks your baby has
in the last few years has released more
classified documents than the rest of
the world's media combined can that
possibly be true
yeah can it possibly be true it's a
worry isn't it that the rest of the
world's media is doing such a bad job
that a little
group of activists is able to release
more of that type of information than
the rest of world press combined
years earlier an auto executive turned
defense secretary charles wilson said
what's good for general motors is good
for america he saw no distinction
between an elected government and an
unelected corporation
gm was a car company that became a major
defense supplier buoyed by military
spending and then years later became a
mortgage lender driven by wall street
originated and often fraudulent subprime
loans until it nearly collapsed and had
to be bailed out by government
the united states supreme court in its
citizens united decision has decided
that corporations like gm have the
rights of ordinary people and can openly
and sometimes secretly lobby congress
and the public or finance political
campaigns to promote their agendas
there are now many criticisms against
citizens united many of the arguments
can be seen in this video by the story
of stuff campaign we have a democracy in
crisis
85 percent of americans feel that
corporations have too much power in our
democracy and people have too little 85
percent hey that's a majority
so let's get together and take our
democracy back from the corporations
it's the first and most important step
in making real progress on all the
issues that people care most about
there is also a counter campaign
underway against corporate control of
politics focusing on two billionaire
political donors charles and edward koch
two brothers both industrialists and
both funders of conservative campaigns
including one to suppress voting by
democrats
filmmaker robert greenwald has
distributed this video nationwide
folks like the koch brothers are
attempting to ensure that as few people
of color and as few young people show up
as possible
we live we've undergone a coup d'etat we
live in a corporate state
chris hedges is a best-selling author
and former reporter for the new york
times
the people who rule america are
the large corporate
entities uh which are supernatural they
have no loyalty to the nation state they
are harvesting the country just like
they're harvesting the rest of the globe
they're planning a global neo-feudalism
where workers around the planet have to
be competitive which means being
competitive with sweatshop workers in
bangladesh who make 22 cents an hour or
prison labor in china it's it's a global
neo-feudalism
it's one
that
is
unassailable
completely
untouchable and more powerful than the
host governments that
were there nominally based hedges is not
alone in this view professor michael
claire specializes in studying the
country's largest industry oil and gas
i would say that the oil industry or
energy writ large coal natural gas
uranium
is the most powerful lobby in america
the most powerful economic interest and
it's tied to other powerful interests
automobile highway construction suburbia
many other industries tourism are all
linked to energy and they work together
to keep america addicted to oil and to
avoid the transition to alternative
fuels do they have an influence on our
politics do they have an influence on
what happens in washington what happens
in the ballot boxes of america they're
the biggest contributors to electoral
campaigns in general
especially to the republican party and i
think they have a very powerful
influence do you think most americans
know how powerful they are only the
people who see this power
in their daily lives have grasped the
strength of it
for many americans the
military-industrial complex is seen only
as a source of jobs and in fact military
contractors win political support and
federal funds by promising to create
jobs
there are real jobs people working in
the weapons factories and all the
subsidiary subcontractors but it's a
fraud because you could take those same
dollars and put it into any other
industry into infrastructure green
energy education or even into tax cuts
for working people and produce more jobs
than you do with the military spending
so it's worse than nothing purely on the
economic terms
for years there have been protests
against america's wars and the military
but most have targeted politicians not
necessarily the corporations who profit
from making weapons and other products
for the military
one of the groups that's most visible
and challenging militarism is a woman's
group code pink medea benjamin is a
co-founder
i've learned that we don't rule america
i've learned that the
democrats
don't rule america
the
corporations rule america i've been
doing the work on the
wars and i've just been floored at how
powerful these weapons manufacturers are
and how powerful the contractors are and
that they have the ability to kind of
keep wars going i mean that's that's
pretty amazing when you think about it
like i'm just doing a lot of work around
the drones issue do you know there's a
drones caucus in congress i mean instead
of having a caucus to feed preschool
children you know they decide it was
more important to have a drone caucus
and that's because all the manufacturers
in their
districts are funding them
they're quite open about it and in fact
over 50 members of congress have created
a caucus
for drones a car where they openly
promote the use and sale of drones at
home and abroad and then they've now
authorized the the the flight of at
least third of up to 30 000 drones in
u.s skies for whatever purpose
this this is in contrast to the lack of
any caucus
for senior citizens for children for
health coverage for green energy for for
human beings there's a caucus for robots
eisenhower was so right and he was so
right when he said that it steals money
it robs us of food for our children of
health care for our parents he was so
right and it's just worse and worse and
you get the little puppets in congress
and i live in washington now so i see
these little puppets and wish that they
were like the nascar drivers that had to
have their corporations on their suits
but they don't rule america the
corporations obviously rule america and
when it comes to war and peace those
corporations are so powerful that
they've kept us for the last decade and
more and if we don't do something about
it they'll keep us in war for the next
decade
beyond the debates about the role of the
military there may be a deeper challenge
because the united states has evolved
from a nation into an empire with a
far-flung system of bases economic
interests and intertangled business
dealings all around the world
top political leaders interact with
corporate leaders at meetings of elites
like the bilderberg conference the
trilateral commission and the
international monetary fund meetings
it's all part of a global structure of
corporate culture politics and power
some like the billionaire george soros
told me a while back that the world
economic forum is more like a networking
party than a decision-making venue
decisions are often made behind the
scenes not at public events
the divorce meeting is a
enormous
sort of cocktail party
uh a lot of contacts people meet and so
on a lot of things are discussed it's
actually very convenient because you can
meet a lot of people whom you want to
meet in in a con
confined period of time and it's also a
media event is it also a symbol of the
growth of sort of economic power of over
political power lack of sovereign a loss
of sovereignty by some
countries um
well it is actually symptomatic of the
age because you have
uh
presidents and prime ministers courting
the the the the financiers and the
industrialists
only a few americans seem to understand
how corporatization and globalization go
hand in hand walter teague was one of
the first activists against the vietnam
war he believes that americans can't see
the facts because they're trapped in
myths i asked him how he would explain
this situation to people on mars
i'd have to explain some very crazy
things to them i'd have to explain it in
terms
that they would perhaps understand i'd
have to not use
some of the terms that americans
commonly use
because
if you use the language that we're
taught in school about democracy
free
free will
you know all of the how the united
states is number one uber alice right
all those terms lead the person to not
being capable of understanding
what you're saying which is that there
are
really and have been for a long time a
very small percentage one percent or
something like that
really make most of the decisions but
they are smart enough
to make them in a way that keeps
most americans until
recently from realizing that they're
being ruled
we cannot undo the plutocracy the
kleptocracy the lack of representation
without dismantling the
military-industrial complex this is the
one percent of the one percent this is
where we give a banker bailout every
year and we don't get a dime of it back
we borrow it from china we pay it back
with interest we keep interest rates
ridiculously low we crash wall street we
bail it out because we've created a war
economy without any need for war well i
think if people had a better sense of
how these companies how the uniform
military how their allies in congress
are basically running the show
scaring us into spending on weapons we
don't need
i think they'd have the beginnings of a
tool to do something about it but i
think absent that information there's
sort of nowhere to start there's nowhere
to sort of plant your feet and try to
fight back against it so i'd have to
tell the martians it's going to be very
hard for you to understand
why americans don't see
how they're being screwed
they don't see it except when it gets so
bad or so contradictory or so blatant or
so personal and then they wake up one
day and say oh my god
does this mean in a way that business
that wall street that
defense contractors than others have
disproportionate power
in other words are they kind of one of
the forces ruling our country that most
people don't even know about
i think that the money has
great influence uh across the board
particularly where the issues are arcane
and they seem
disassociated with the average americans
where constituents aren't paying
attention and they're not being heard by
their representatives in washington i
think where people are paying attention
where it becomes a
there is a hue and cry from regular
people
it's hard for the money to
to beat out the merits on policy
politicians usually will not risk the
political liability
of being seen as catering to their
the interest bankrolling their campaign
if
the voters are paying attention they're
usually not that
that unwise
most of the public doesn't interface
with the military-industrial complex
because they participate in the economy
as consumers
but even there they're being affected by
a power shift an economic inequality
that drives them deeper and deeper into
debt
george scribner is an executive with a
corporation that advises other
corporations
today it takes two hundred thousand
dollars a year to feel somewhat affluent
i asked george scribner how he thinks
growing inequality is affecting our
politics who's in charge of our country
we keep reading more and more about big
money in politics
there was a great article of the one
percent by the one percent for the one
percent and i think it might have been
vanity fair but i'm not positive right
now
but they made a point that i in politics
that i've been making in terms of
business
is that for you know since world war ii
it was
head count that made a difference one
person one vote so you go you play to
the to the vote you know
one person one dollar you played to as
many people as you could to get the
dollars
now because the assets
are concentrated at the high end in the
hands of the few
actually money is much more valuable
both to politicians
and to marketers
than the mass of people that comprise
the middle class so is the mass of
people being left out now are they
massive americans they certainly they
aren't being left out but they're
certainly
less important
so i think in a variety of ways you'll
see them being less catered to and
manipulated more in a sense
and in politics and in terms of
marketing there'll be fewer products and
fewer services
that's one view from inside the
corporate world essentially saying that
the majority of americans have less
economic power and as a result less
political power
people with money rule america because
people with money can
acquire power through that but we all
have the great thing about america is
all we all live within the myth
that each one of us can make a
difference and i think there are enough
opportunities for that to happen
that makes me think that the future will
be
won't be as bleak as it seems sometimes
let's hope so certainly most americans
believe their future is bright but given
the trends we've explored about who's in
power there certainly are doubts
especially because of the danger and
threat of new wars that are being
planned secretly according to professor
stanley aranowitz
there'll be a war against iran there as
a matter of fact unless you refuse to a
count um
embargoes um
things like that are going on at this
very moment that is to say in march of
2012 that's an act of that is virtually
an act of war
that we are saying to the iranians
either you bow to our demand that you do
not develop nuclear weapons and you
renounce nuclear weapons or otherwise we
will continue to to borrow your goods
from going back and forth
i mean after all the market is part of
the the system so they're saying you
have no market rights so there is a war
underway right now i think so but most
americans don't really know it do they
that's right they really know about this
power elite do they really know about
what c wright mills talked about so many
years ago why is that and how can that
change because we don't have a left that
really is
continually in an effective way
talks about who has power in america we
haven't
the occupy movement talked about 99
being deprived of uh economic uh power
and about inequality but it is not even
close to being an analysis that can be
uh disseminated throughout the entire
society we don't have it we don't have a
daily news system of daily newspapers we
don't have a weekly newspaper we have
twitter we have you know
various other kinds of social media that
we have access to but it does not
replace the kind of systematic analysis
that could take place as a result of
having our own media so americans in a
way are still in the dark and i think
you know the left forum and so many
other efforts are attempts to challenge
that to change that well yes that's
right
even as president eisenhower exposed the
military military-industrial complex he
also expressed a very american deeply
felt desire for peace and justice that
history has largely forgotten from the
earth
and that in the goodness of time
all peoples will come to live together
in a piece guaranteed
by the binding force
of mutual respect and love
[Music]
coming up in the next episode of who
rules america the power of the media
ambassador
so if you're looking at who rules
america or who owns america
it's the same people that propagandize
to america
next time on who rules america
you